- I bind because it kind of
quiets that dysphoria that I get.
I bind because it makes me
feel safer when I'm outside.
I bind because I think I look a lot hotter
when I'm in a binder than when I'm not.
(slow music)
- I started binding about a year ago.
- Two years.
- Maybe eight months ago.
- Six years.
- I first started binding when
I was a teenager in college.
- Almost five and half
years I binded, straight.
(slow music)
- You kind of just wear it like a tank top
and, you know, it just
totally flattens your chest.
- I think I had like
double D's and I would
put on the binder and it
would probably go down
two sizes just because it's so tight
and it's like a suction cup almost.
It's just holding
everything tightly together.
- So, this is the one that I got during
my freshman year (laughs) of college.
You can see it's very,
very, very stretched out
and like, you can see through it.
- I'm not sure how this hole
happened, but it's there.
- I like to be androgynous,
so I feel like this helps me achieve that.
- I don't know, I was
just really uncomfortable
in T-shirts and I wear
a lot of button shirts.
- Pretty open about it 'cause
I complain about it a lot.
I also have friends who
are in the same situation
where they also can't afford top surgery.
(slow music)
- It allowed me to go
out into public with,
you know, a shirt on and
just be able to seen as a guy
because, you know, it
was before top surgery.
- If I didn't have my
binder, I couldn't function.
I just couldn't go out, I
couldn't have dinner with friends.
I couldn't talk to family
because I wasn't the Renee,
the whole Renee or as
closest to the whole Renee
I could be without my binder with me.
- I've had dysphoria
from, with my breasts,
since they grew in.
I tried to use regular
tape to tape 'em down,
so I was like what's happening?
What is this little knot in my chest?
- I have a lot of fear of,
you know, getting assaulted
or just being stared at in public
'cause I definitely don't
like to leave my apartment
without my binder even to go to
the corner store to buy a cup of coffee.
- When you put it on
and it's what you want
and what you need, it's
the most euphoric feeling.
You're like, "Yes, I'm complete."
- And seeing kind of a
silhouette that looks right
instead of these weird
lumps in front of me.
- They tell you to bind
correctly or it'll hurt,
but I feel like binding just
doesn't feel good at all.
- It was 77 degrees yesterday in New York
and I was just, sweat
was pouring down my body.
- (sighs) It feels really
good to take it off.
- When people think about binding,
they might think it's very constricting,
something that's painful,
why would you wanna do that
to your body, but it's just a way
to kind of connect our mind to our body.
- I didn't want to look like
or feel like I had breasts.
Even though binding does help give
that appearance that they are gone,
it is a strong reminder
that they are there.
- Sometimes you're
gonna put that binder on
and it's not going to
change anything for you
and it's okay to have those moments.
- There's not a lot of discussions,
especially outside of the
trans community about binding
and I think that more
people should talk about it
and we should be allowed
to be more open about it
and feel more free
having these discussions.
(peaceful music)